what's up guys I'm going to do something
a little bit different because I am so
bogged down with videos I have to do and
with schoolwork and a short film I'm in
post-production on and this whole defy
media thing I still haven't heard
anything by the way in regards to what's
going on with the two months that are
owed a lot of other creators have
reached out to me who are also in a
similar position I feel you guys I feel
it I understand trust me it sucks there
there's nothing good about it hopefully
some positive things can come out of it
I was just interviewed by a big outlet
there that's gonna probably be going out
pretty soon and maybe that'll help push
some things into action I don't know
that being said I simply don't have the
time to do like a billion videos for for
these movies I haven't talked about in
TV show I am still going to do a big
video about the haunting of Hill House
because I love that show so much I don't
want to cram it into a big video I want
to take the time to really talk about
that but I want to get some films out of
the way that I did see that people are
requesting me to talk about in this
video I'm gonna do it a little quicker
than usual because that's just what I
have to do right now in my life I gotta
get this out of the way I have a lot on
my plate right now
so sorry that these aren't in-depth but
I don't really have a choice I don't
have the time so let's start with the
Grinch
[Music]
the Grinch was all right it I don't know
like it's completely inoffensive it's a
cartoon movie with the Grinch that
follows the basic narrative structure of
dr. Seuss's book except adding a few
things here and there and making a few
things longer is it as good as the
original like 30 minute cartoon no is it
as good as Jim Carrey's Grinch it kind
of depends on how you view that movie
like adults of that era really didn't
like it but kids really liked that movie
and so if you were like really attached
to Jim Carrey's Grinch then then I feel
like you're probably just gonna watch
this and think man I wish Jim Carrey was
doing this or I wish it was some sort of
continuation of that Benedict
Cumberbatch does a good job with the
voice work it's a beautiful looking
movie
I think young kids will really like it
but for me I was kind of bored with it
it's it's fine I'd give the Grinch a C+
I also saw Overlord the new JJ Abrams
produced film that a lot of people
thought was going to be a Cloverfield
movie it's not this is a film that takes
place during the Nazi reign in Germany
and we have soldiers who encounter Nazis
who are experimenting and turning
themselves into zombies and now we have
a war film which was fine it was
enjoyable I didn't give a shit about a
single character in this movie if every
single character got blown up and then
it was just like zombies running around
I would not have cared that's easily
that my biggest flaw with the movie is
that there was just not much
characterization I just didn't really
feel invested in the film but it was
action heavy enough and well acted
enough to appreciate there wasn't enough
zombies either like I imagine the pitch
for this movie was hey what about a
movie during the Nazi stuff in Germany
but with zombies but there's just not
that many zombies and so you kind of
lose out on the fact that it takes a
while for the movie to commit to its
absurdities it's like is it a war film
or is it a crazy absurd zombie movie
with tons of blood once it commits it's
really entertaining
I'd give Overlord a beam
- all right Bohemian Rhapsody now this
one I've been requested to do a lot I am
a humongous fan of Queen my wife and I
were talking the other day if we could
go back in time and see any band live it
would be Queen a musical artist solo
Michael Jackson but a band Queen adore
them Freddie Mercury was a musical
genius and so I was super excited for
this movie and there's a lot to like in
it and I know that fans are drooling
over this movie and critics were kind of
mixed on it there's a lot to like about
the movie name namely Ramy Malick who is
basically Freddie Mercury reincarnated
at least when he's performing Freddie
Mercury in person in private was
apparently a lot more reserved and
introverted than the depiction of his
character in this film very extroverted
and you know it loves to talk to people
and very open in real life from what I
understand from doing research on him
over the course of my life because like
I said I love Queen he was a little bit
more introverted but the performance is
holy shit I mean the recreation of the
Live Aid concert the tongue flicker him
looking between his legs the Pepsi
bottles on the piano the way he would
stand and pose with the microphone it
just incredible recreation of an iconic
concert so the performance aspect of
Bohemian Rhapsody I thought was
wonderful it's a bit of a mixed bag for
me though whenever he's not performing
because I found the movie took a very
safe approach to a man who did a lot I
mean this guy did drugs and he
unfortunately died of AIDS and yet it's
just like very sanitized and safe the
movie rarely focuses on the sadder times
and when it does it rains on him and
other really tired movie cliches it just
avoids a lot of things I would have
loved to have seen them talk about like
they mentioned Michael Jackson his
manager during a scene says Michael
Jackson sold four percent of all albums
this year and it doesn't even talk about
the fact that during the early eighties
Freddie Mercury in Michael Jackson
collaborated on songs they just weren't
released until later it's like the film
just sticks
access to only care about his greatest
hits they'd barely talk about under
pressure and David Bowie either it's
just playing in the background briefly
now maybe they thought it was a little
bit too soon since he recently passed to
have somebody portray Bowie in the movie
that could be there's just a lot that
they glossed over and there's a lot of
factually inaccurate stuff too
I don't really consider this a spoiler
but I guess if you don't know anything
about Freddie Mercury's life I already
kind of spoiled it by saying that he
eventually died of AIDS but in the film
in 1985 right before the Live Aid
concert he tells the band that he was
diagnosed but he wasn't diagnosed in
real life until 1987 so there's a lot of
stuff like that in the film that bug me
as a big fan of Freddie Mercury yeah if
you like the music you can go and see
somebody really wonderfully recreate it
and you can celebrate that life and you
should it's certainly not an awful movie
and I do think it's a bit better than
critics are saying but it was far too
safe for my taste I mean this is a guy
who stood on stage and rift with the
audience and then directly told the
audience fuck you
EW
[Applause]
and this is a pg-13 movie where he says
Freddie fucking mercury once and I'm
like this this guy was a lot harder edge
than this and I found that annoying I'm
gonna give Bohemian Rhapsody a C+ bad
times at El Royale I really loved I
found this to be an extremely well
directed film that juggled a lot of
storylines very carefully Drew Goddard
directed the film I did have a chance to
meet back in 2012 when cabin in the
woods came out he came to an Ohio
screening of it in Columbus and I drove
down there to meet him really nice guy I
thought he did an excellent job I loved
all the performances I really enjoyed
the way this movie tied itself together
it takes its time considerably it sets
up little nuggets of things asks you to
be patient about it and then later
you'll find out more about it sometimes
it can be a little frustrating because
you're like that doesn't make any sense
and then you just tell yourself wait
you'll you'll you'll get it you'll
figure it out and of course it does
Chris Hemsworth I thought played a
really good villain I loved the whole
third act I think my only real issue
with the movie were a few character
choices some scenes were a bit too slow
and maybe thought they were a little
bigger than they were but I really
enjoyed this movie and I recommend you
check it out I'm gonna give it a B+
Mandy starring Nicolas Cage easily one
of my most anticipated films of the year
any time one of the first photos you
release of a film is Nicolas Cage
covered in blood
then I'm extremely happy first half of
the movie very different from the last
half the last half is pretty much
exactly what I was hoping the entire
film would be like as soon as I seen in
a bathroom everything after that I'm
like yep this is what I want love it
perfection Nicolas Cage I love you
you're a genius
really beautifully shot film sometimes
though the use of post-processed grain
and lens flares from nothing or very
annoying sometimes scenes that were very
very pink we're just almost like I
bleeding and so horrible to look at that
I
was so confused as to why it was on the
screen for as long as it was and then
other scenes were just gorgeous the
first half I've seen it twice now is a
bit slow and a bit hard to get through
on the second viewing there's a lot to
love about this movie the music the
performances Nick Cage especially it's
just that I feel like at times the
director was was getting in the way of
the film people wanted and that's just
me I I certainly would highly recommend
the movie there's just aspects of the
first half that it felt like I was
waiting for the movie to get going
waiting for the movie they marketed but
I would recommend Mandy purely on its
originality Nick Cage and a director who
definitely has a vision who is really
interested in seeing your reaction to
that vision and I think he has a bright
future I'm gonna give Mandy a beat all
right daredevil season 3 I would love to
make a whole video about this but I just
don't have the time first four to five
episodes I was kind of waiting to get
really into it like I liked it Fisk
being back Vincent D'Onofrio holy shit
what an actor it was getting into it but
it was kind of like all right we're
getting close and then minor spoilers I
guess but as soon as Matt caught that
weapon in front of foggy space holy shit
this season became my favorite season of
all of their devil the rest of it was a
nail-biting exercise in perfectly
executed tension I was so pleased with
the writing with the character choices
with the action scenes with the way they
shuffled these people around to create
maximum tension and suspense daredevil
season 3 really gave me what I wanted
holy shit Vincent D'Onofrio can act
my god what a man I was in men and black
I played the villain in that movie and I
was also in Full Metal Jacket
where's daredevil where's Vanessa this
suck they did with bullseye like having
that like insect like sound buzzing in
his head exploring his psychosis
I liked the
- back episode with Karen I thought that
was a really great idea sure it killed a
little bit of the moment if you are
binge watching but if you take a little
bit of breaks between episodes it flows
really nice and there was a line earlier
in the show where she called her dad and
looked for help and he was like kind of
dismissive of her and I remember being
like what that's kind of weird but then
when you see the flashback episode it's
like I understand now and it sets you up
for possibilities really starting to
worry about Karen you know and it's one
of those seasons where you it really
does feel like just anybody could die
and that's rare for a TV show because
you're usually expecting more but this
season had that that tension all
throughout where you really felt like
just anybody's disposable I'm gonna give
daredevil season 3 and a guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to a review of fantastic beasts
2 as well as a full video on the
haunting of Hill House again sorry I had
to cram all this into one but I just
don't have the time right now to focus
on doing separate videos for all of
those but I did go and see all of them I
just I got to get all this caught up to
date I'm still manually one-by-one
monetizing all my old videos it's taken
me a week I've gotten through half of
them that is by far the most tedious
meticulous boring thing I've ever done
in my life but I'm I'm working through
it
and I just want to also thank you guys
for all the messages of support that
I've gotten on YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook and patreon like you guys have
been amazing thank you so much for
understanding the shitty situation that
so many other people are in because of
it a whole defy media thing hopefully
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
but if not I'm still here and I'm
talking thank you guys as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]